اكيد انا عامل وقد هو العمل الحاسم في هذا
نوع من الاصابات غالبا ما يخسر الجنود
والمدنيون كميات كبيره من الدماء بعد
الاصابه لذلك النقطه المهمه للغايه هي هذه
المراكز الطبيه الموجوده في الاماكن
المتقدمه هذه مراكز ليست مجهزه مثلا
لاجراء العمليه هدفها تثبيت حاله المصابين
كي يتم نقلهم في مرحله لاحقه الى مراكز
خلفيه وتوزيعهم على مستشفيات ممتده على
طول الجبهه هذا مشاهدناه اليوم همم في همم
زيارتنا همم حيث همم كنا في احد هذه
المراكز عندما وصل جدي اصيب بشاظايا بعد
سقوط قديفه تهاون بالقرب منها راينا كيف
يقوم الاطباء بما يلزم همم طبعا في هذا
المركز هناك مثلا ادويه هناك الات لكن
ظروف التعقيم غير حاضره كما اا اكد لنا
الطبيب العامل همم هناك ذلك ان الجنود
يصلون كما هم من الجبهه احيانا همم تكون
ثيابهم وهي امر طبيعي في ساحات القتال
متسخه الكثير من الدماء الامر كله احيانا
يبقى في هذه الغرف مع الصعوبه في تنظيفها
اللي مثلا لنستمع الى ما قاله لنا طبيب
موجود هناك همم نعرف اكثر الصوره في هذه
المراكز
لدينا مشكله مع التدفئه طبعا الطقس بارد
ونستخدم معدات كهذا
لكنها تعمل بالكهرباء وتلك تنقطع احيانا
كثيره لا تصلنا المياه في الحنفيه نحمل
اوعيه مياه الى هنا لكنها غير كافيه لكن
هذه المشاكل تواجهنا وتواجه الجميع في
جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
في ظل هذه الظروف
اذا كان هذا طبيب عمل في مركز مالي علاج
الجرحى في مدينه تورت هذا الطبيب هو طبيب
متطوع كان مسؤول عن عمليات التخدير في
احدى مستشفياتك وهو واحد من الاف الاطباء
الذين تركوا اماكن عملهم واتوا الى
الجبهات هذا علما اننا ايضا نعلم ان هناك
اطباء عسكريين لكن هؤلاء على عكس هذا
الطبيب الذي رايناه يعملون احيانا لفترات
عمل طويله تصل الى اربعه اشهر وفي ظروف
صعبه لكن هذه المراكز الاهميه تقوم بعلاج
همم المصابين بالحرب وتستطيع ان تنقذ وهذا
ما ثبت فعلا حياه كثيرين بانتظار تثبيت
حالتهم ونقلهم الى مراكز اكثر تجهيزه
انت اليوم كنت همم في احدى القواعد
المتقدمه للجنود الاوكرانيين
فيسك كيف بدل مشهد
القاعده التي ااا زرتها قريبه اكثر من
بلده تسمى نيويورك اللافه اليوم كان هذا
الهدوء على الجبهه هذه تحديدا عندما سالنا
لماذا اتى الجواب على محورين المحور الاول
هو وجود الضباب الكثيف ماء عاق
وصول الطائرات بدون تيار وهذا ما يصاعد
عمليات البحث عن الاهداف للجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي وربما هذا ما ساعدنا ان
نصل الى حوالي بعد كيلو مترين من الجبه
هناك راينا خطا دفاعيا وقاعده هي قاعده
تعتبر اساسيه لاستراحه الجنود الامر في
همم نهايه المطاف كان عباره عن بيت
استخدامه همم الجنود الاوكرانيون اللافت
مثلا هذا المشهد الذي ينطبع في ذهن احد
الجنود هناك انا اتناول طعامي على هذه
الطاوله هذا الصحن الى جانبي وهذه يعني
عندما نظرت الى اصبعه كان يشير لي الى
قنبله على الطاوله وفي كل همم
الغرف في هذا المنزل كانت معدات الحياه
اليوميه للجنود الاوكرانيين اضافه الى
قنابل اضافه الى همم
البنادق ومعدات اخرى في هذا هذه النقطه
تحديدا عمليه القتال كما قال لي الجنود
تشتدوا ليلا وتتم احيانا عبر التقدم ذلك
احيانا يكون الفارق بين في المسافه بين
الجنود الاوكرانيين والجنود الروس لا
تتجاوز ال 800 متر علما انه في هذه البقعه
المراكز القتاليه يعود تاريخها الى العام
2014 قال لي الجنود الاوكرانيون هم يعرفون
مواقعنا ونحن نعرف مواقعهم وبالتالي نقوم
بعمليات الضرب والهروب سريعا لكن الطقس
الحالي هنا في اوكرانيا رغ البارد لكنها
تمطر والوحول كثيفه في الحقول وفي هذا
الريف الواسع وهذا ما يعيق العمليات ذلك
مثلا الدبابات لا تستطيع ان تتقدم هي
بحاجه الى ارض صلبه همم الكل ينتظر ان
تهبط اكثر درجات الحراره لكي يتمكن من
القيام بعمليات واسعه النقاط الان
العمليات اتحدث عن هذا المحور فقط تشمل
المدفعيه الهاون
ولكل يراقب حاله الطقس لمعرفه كيفيه
التقدم في الحقول بلا ان تصاب الاليات
باثر كبير لكن هذا لا يعني ابدا هدوء على
الجبهه لكن اليوم كان هناك هذا الوضع الذي
وصفوه لي بالاستثناء وغير اعتيادي بل يثير
الريبه بالنسبه اليهم بانتظار ان يحل
المساء وللمساء ولليل قصه اخرى مع التكتي
الحربيه وكيفيه الهجوم والدفاع في هذه
النقطه ميس عواد موفدتنا الخاصه الى دروش
كيف شكرا جزيلا لك